hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and people who like science it's
very natural often also enjoy science
fiction we like to think that science
fiction is the literature of ideas right
that science fiction takes us places
puts human beings in situations where
ordinary fiction which is constrained by
reality might not let us go so there's
opportunities within science fiction to
ask questions and to examine existing
questions in ways that would otherwise
not be possible so today we have an
interesting angle in the science fiction
universe we're talking to Seth
MacFarlane the actor director writer who
is famous for of course things like
Family Guy the animated show movies like
Ted and Once Upon a Time in the West and
set also has albums he's a singer and a
ranger of music but the project that
he's working on that I'm most interested
for this conversation is the Orville
this is as you might know science
fiction TV show that appears on Fox it
just completed its second season third
season will be upcoming and it's
basically Star Trek with some comedic
touches I think in the early days people
were a little confused about what the
Orville was supposed to be it had
dramatic elements and comedic elements
and it took about half a season I would
say in season one to find its feet
really but now to be honest not just
because Seth is on the show I think this
is one of the most interesting TV shows
out there they are really using the
medium of science fiction to talk about
issues that are very very relevant to us
here on earth right now so that's what
Seth agreed to talk about and we had a
very interesting thoughtful discussion
about how you come up with these
scenarios how they do relate to what's
going here on earth you know how the
real world cannot help but affect your
science fictional drama that you're
writing and hopefully backwards how
thinking about these new things in the
science fictional setting can give us
new handles on the problems we have here
on earth
so I think it's a very rewarding
conversation and also you know the first
thing that comes up and everyone admits
it's true is that Seth has a really
wonderful voice for radio or podcasts so
that's always always makes it a pleasant
experience I think you're gonna like
this one
let's go
[Music]
seth macfarlane welcome to mindscape
podcast thank you very much
so you seem to be able to keep busy it
seemed to have a lot going on I know you
have had TV shows and movies various
forms of tark talking animals and
talking stuffed animals but I really
wanted to concentrate on the Orval the
this science-fiction show which I've
become a big fan of why don't we say
what the show is for the few of us in
the audience who don't know you know the
show is is kind of a classic style
episodic sci-fi adventure series that
that that sort of a adheres to the
traditional sci-fi method of
storytelling which is to take elements
of our society you know whether it be
social or political or scientific and
and find ways to tell stories about
those things in an allegorical fashion
through the lens of sci-fi and you know
for me I grew up with with episodic
sci-fi I grew up with things like The
Twilight Zone and obviously Star Trek
and and you know I I miss that style of
storytelling which I was I could see a
self-contained show that was based
around an idea as opposed to a twist hmm
and I think in the age of that's a good
way of putting it like what so what well
yeah in the age of streaming shows where
you're dealing with a story arc that
lasts throughout the season it's kind of
hard to to explore a lot of different
areas of it's it's it's hard to tell the
the diversity of stories becomes less in
that format and it starts to become
about how can I surprise the audience
with a crazy twist rather than what used
to be the case is how what new idea can
I present to the audience this week and
you really can only do that with
self-contained stories I think yeah and
certainly I'm a big fan of a lot of the
you know cable prestige drama long
series but there's absolutely a place
that's all we're getting now I know
exactly and I miss you know
procedurals monsters of the week and
ever yeah I mean it's it's it's nice to
you know one of the mission statements
of the Orville is that is that you know
within reason you know we do like to
reward our fans for for for sticking
with us but it also should be something
where you don't have to commit to an
entire season right off the bat if you
don't want you can watch one hour and
we'll tell you a story
that doesn't require you to have
followed every soap opera twist that's
come before it and and that's you know I
there's nothing there's no television
show you can watch now where the first
episode doesn't insist that you stick
around for the next 8 or 13 yeah it does
it create pressure on you or the writers
to go up with a new plot every week yeah
I mean it's you know it's it's it's a
different kind of you know opposite to
to map out a serialized arc throughout
the course of a season is is a lot of
work but I do think that at the end of
the day that's that's a that's one idea
that you're it's one story that you're
telling over the course of eight or ten
episodes to come up with a brand new
idea every week you know it's it I have
such a renewed respect for guys like
Serling particularly at a time when
there was nothing to really there was no
template to work from he had to reinvent
the wheel that he was able to bring a
brand new idea every week yeah and and
not just for 13 for 22 and the Twilight
Zone was obviously one of the
inspirations even more obviously Star
Trek was an inspiration so let's just
tell the audience you have a spaceship
you're on the bridge yeah aliens yeah I
mean it's it's interesting that the the
the idea of a what is in effect a naval
ship in space rather than on the waters
is something that's been around since I
mean it's probably I probably since
before the 1930s but obviously in film
that seems to be where where it it
emerged in the most memorable way with
the serialized
films that that that come from that era
you know Star Trek was the first
franchise to really solidify it as it as
a you know kind of work out the kinks
and it's interesting if you watch Star
Wars or Buck Rogers these subsequent
shows and they're all kind of taking
cues from the original Star Trek I mean
you know when Star Wars uses the term
cloaking device it it's you know that's
something that they got from from Star
Trek yeah yeah yeah attract you
absolutely yeah they just they you know
they they there's a road toolbox there
they wrote the book for for all of us
and it's really just how you want to use
it and you know I think for us if if the
Star Trek franchise was doing that
particular thing at this point in time
then there might not be a place for the
orbital but because they're not there
they're they've gone more of the
streaming serialized direction it's left
this big wide opening that we've been
able to step into with our show and it's
and you know we've been having a blast
so I take it you are a Star Trek fan
going up with you science fiction
Vantage I was yeah yeah I wasn't I was
kind of picky and choosey about the
sci-fi that I never really got into
Blade Runner or Battlestar Galactica or
these kind of hard sci-fi I really it
was a big fan of Star Trek big fan of
The Twilight Zone
you know III enjoyed some Ray Ray
Bradbury some of it got a little too
heady for me when I was a kid so your it
was reading as well as TV movie yeah
yeah I used to when I was a Heinlein guy
myself at that age but he also as a
model at origin and yeah sturgeon it's
interesting I bought a collection of his
short stories and they're really out
there there then it's interesting
there's a lot of comedy in his writing
it's a lot of mix mixing sci-fi and
comedy and some of them are some of them
are very much of their time but others
are you know have these little snippets
of wisdom that are applicable to ours
did you how long have you been thinking
about doing a sci-fi show yeah
for some time this this show was this
show emerged
originally the Orval was going to be a
I've written is sort of a feature idea
and then very quickly decided now this
is there's nothing like this on TV right
now
it was the initial version of it was
very comedy heavy and when I look back
at it I I realized that that wasn't
really the show that I wanted to do that
since we've kind of veered I'd only
taken that pressure off ourselves and
veered more towards into geared more
towards um traditional science fiction
without the pressure of having to have
that comedy frosting on it to such a
degree I've been having a lot more fun I
realized this is it's I mean even more
so than writing Family Guy it just comes
it just comes flowing out it's it's it's
it's easier so maybe I never should have
been a cop you're right in the first
place we discover ourselves yeah I've
done yet
yeah but it's it's I mean it's it's a
blast it's it's and it's gratifying to
see that people were fans were willing
to willing and ready in many cases eager
to see that from us I I think a lot of
it initially was fear that no one would
take me seriously if I wrote a sci-fi
show and it's I've been pleasantly
disproven well I thought was very
interesting the initial reaction to the
show not just what it was but from whom
the I'm getting it correctly like if you
go onto the professional critics season
one reviews they were not good yeah but
the audience loved it
yes and season two it's caught up right
they and where did that was at the
evolution of the show or really
educating I think I think some of it was
the evolution of the show I think I
think the the minority of the the
smaller portion was the evolution of the
show I don't think the show changed that
much because we did one of the thing one
of the episodes we did show the critics
initially was the about a girl episode
about Boris's baby that's a big one
and that gets pretty you know for season
one that gets pretty pretty dark again
yeah and they were I I think what
happened was it took them a minute to
realize that we weren't trying to do the
serialized format that everyone else is
doing and and that we were you know the
whole point was to let the story dictate
the tone and I mean look on the original
Star Trek you see a lot of that there's
there there there's there are episodes
that are very dark very dramatic they're
episodes that feel more like a comedy
and trouble with tribbles right yeah
yeah and I you know I see it as I mean
look life is that way you have one day
where it's your birthday and you fall in
the swimming pool by accident another
day where you lose a family member and
it's it's those are those days have very
different tones and and it's all the
same life but it feels very different
and there's television you know
television can reflect that and and if
the characters have to be consistent and
they're how there has they have to be
your anchor but beyond that I think
there's there's no reason that the story
can't dictate what the tone is if you're
telling an episodic story that's
self-contained and I think that's what
threw the critics I think with with
three episodes they felt like this thing
was disjointed and look I mean I first
for whatever reason you know when I they
always come out swinging when I do
something new anyway yeah there's a
little bit of that well there's a little
bit of the reviews being written before
the thing came up but but I was I was
yeah don't you try to ignore it but at
the same time it's gratifying when you
see that nice big fat round tomato and
that 100% that's I feel good I don't you
do read the comments in other words let
I have my little podcast and I try not
to but yeah it's a social thing that
we're doing yeah it's it's for
television it's it's and I'm actually
out for a podcast as well I imagine like
you're doing something for an audience
so there is a partnership between you
and the audience you know with I mean
most a lot of what you do those science
based right on the podcast not quite 50
percent yeah and but because that's
that's where it gets dicey is that you
you know this this idea that you know
can't we all just have different
opinions well no you can on this but not
really on that you know with
entertainment with something like the
Orville it's it's it's very you know I'm
very curious as I can I mean I read it's
sometimes it's torture but you know I'll
read read it I'll read YouTube comments
already Twitter or I'll read Instagram
you know I'll just get as much
information as I can't just just a cuz
it's it's fun to see people talking
about it and sci-fi fans are so
passionate about you know about what
they like and what they don't like and
and it's you try to balance it between
your own vision of where you want the
show to go and what it is they want to
see because and I think if you can
thread that needle you're you're doing
something right I think I think you
can't let him guide you completely but
it's done time you can't but you can
learn something like they're not idiots
alright no no it's you know it's it's
it's really I mean it's it's interesting
the Isaac two-parter that we did our
second season was something that was a
big question mark for us we had it was
dark and it was big and it was pure
sci-fi and I had no idea whether people
were gonna where the people were gonna
respond to that or not and they not only
respond to it it was the most popular
set of episodes to date for the series
and the rest of that season kind of put
the Isaac story on hold because we had
written them all in advance and I didn't
realize it was going to be that
successful so but I you know reading as
much of what I did online I discovered
how people want to know what the
aftermath of this is and so we you know
I mean time I I hear him and where we're
dealing with that in season three and
probably when the show first came out
there were expectations right like
you're a comedy writer yeah I think some
of the marketing made it look more like
Galaxy Quest or I'm a Harry D show right
and then people were a little it's a lot
of fear it was a lot of fear on both
sides on the set and and I think the
second season marketing piece that that
Fox did was terrific like I
we thought they did a great job the
first season you know on their from
their end and from my end there was some
fear you know it's it's and I look at
credit jon favreau for for being my
conscience when he directed the pilot
and he he pointed out to me on a number
of occasions you know you have this joke
here and I feel like you're you're
disrupting what is a really good scene
like if he said trust you should trust
that what you have here I'm in I'm into
it I read this script and and and I I
didn't put it down like I wanted to know
what happened I was in it I like the
story the story works and and you don't
need the crutch of all these jokes and
that was from you know I respect him
enormously and so to hear that was kind
of a first step toward me making the
realization that all right maybe maybe I
can do this show that I really wanted to
and yeah and and I don't have to pack it
with pies in the face and people still
watch and yeah I think it is it seems to
evolve to a place where it's different
than a typical sci-fi serialized or even
episodic show because of the jokes but
it's still story and character and
setting based yeah and and in the jokes
the jokes tell you where they want to
appear I mean that you know the
two-parter with Isaac was virtually I
mean there's a couple jokes in there but
that's about it and and it was you know
where they where they show up these days
is you know just comes more from the
casualisation of life on board a
spaceship rather than hard jokes it's
just the behavior the carrots a little
more realistic yeah yeah people are not
quite as stiff as you might see yeah
yeah well yes and it has to be four it's
a tricky line to walk because you want
people to care about what happens you
want to be able to tell a story with big
stakes like we did an identity and
oftentimes that means giving up the the
stick I mean it's like if this is
serious your characters have to treat it
seriously and you just got to embrace
that and so it was nice that the
audience went along with us there and
there's also another slightly different
thing that we don't have in Star Trek is
you know your ex-wife is your yeah
second-in-command and there's a lot more
the personalize the characters a lot
more
socializing yeah well those that that's
that's the part of science fiction that
I don't see enough of I loved you know
it's no cigarette I loved the next
generation for there among other things
for there they're a production design it
was like it it always made sense to me
that if you were in space for that
amount of time you would have to live
somewhere that was comfortable they had
a bar that was a here
grade over the original Star Trek it was
like the sci-fi version of like the
apartment on friends yeah you wanted to
be there every week you wanted to go
back and and that's something that is
that is absolutely absent from science
fiction today all across the board
everything is grim and dark and looks
like you're on a submarine and it's it's
cool to look at but it's just it just
doesn't it's not a place that you want
to live in yeah it seems a little bit
less human I know what you mean yeah but
time and again there's a place for it
but there's also a place for this
slightly lighter yeah I just I I think I
think you should be able to a good
sci-fi show you you should be able to
accommodate all of it you know there's
there's there's your characters should
be strong enough that even if there's no
sci-fi plot you should be able to tell a
dramatic story that week that just
covered that just deals with their lives
so when you started planning out the
show I presumably you had the idea there
would be a starship there would be
cruise some of them would be aliens like
how much was it fun or kind of torture
to sit down and go alright whether the
alien races how are they different um
yeah a little a little bit that's it's
because there's so much science fiction
now it's hard to find hanging fruit has
been picked yeah yeah it's hard to find
things that haven't been that haven't
been dealt with as you go and as you as
you start to to break your stories for
the series what's nice about it is those
races kind of pop up in in the in the
midst of I mean look it's for both the
Simpsons and Family Guy it happened with
our our characters you know I remember
asking cuz it's um Greg Daniels used to
run king of the hill used to I think
wrote on The Simpsons where where did
all these characters
come from this populace of characters in
Springfield and he said you know they
just come they just kind of popped up as
we went along hmm like some a character
would emerge in the middle of a story
and like you know that's good yeah be
funny so let's make that person a part
of the town and eventually the same
thing happened with Family Guy these
characters popped up as we were telling
these stories and you know with the
Orval it's been it's been the same we
will tell a story and and an alien race
will emerge as as part of the narrative
and it works and so we keep them around
let's pause for a minute to talk about
the great courses plus I'm really happy
that for the very first advertisements
we have here on mindscape I get to talk
about a product I truly believe in the
great courses provide accessible
college-level video and audio courses in
a wide variety of subjects from physics
to history to music and much more I've
done three different courses with them
myself and I can vouch for the fact that
there is a rigorous selection process
it's not just that anyone can go and be
a professor for the great courses you
have to audition and you can fail the
audition so you're guaranteed when you
get these courses to get teachers who
love teaching and who are experts in
what they're talking about and the great
courses plus is a streaming service so
you can watch or listen wherever you
want at your convenience either from
your own computer or with the great
courses Plus app on your mobile device
let me also mention my own course
mysteries of modern physics time that's
twenty four half hour lectures about all
the different aspects of time from
physics to philosophy cosmology even the
psychology and neuroscience of time and
for mindscape listeners they have a
special offer if you go to this URL you
can get an entire month for free so you
can start your free month right now by
going to the great courses plus comm
slash mind scape that's the great
courses plus calm slash - cape happy
learning so there are it seems extremely
explicit at least to me that you are
taking advantage of the idea that
science fiction can comment on our
current state our current problems in
various ways you want to mention some of
your favorite I have a long list here of
different things you've done but
um I mean yeah that's that's that's a
broad question you know in other series
are no I'm thinking of his you know the
the obvious example is Bordas when he
basically develops a porn addiction yeah
right yeah on what is the equivalent to
the holodeck yeah yeah but like that was
not an alien worry that's that's a very
human worry no it's it's it's yeah I
think that's I think that episode is the
only time we ever got us standards you
know in the history of the show it by
the way is it it's that's pretty good
it's for me to have that experience it's
like it's like oh that's right there's a
broadcast standards Department I mean we
never hear from them I mean it's ironic
that I I have one show that's been
virtually condemned by the Parents
Television Council and another that's
been roundly endorsed I'm not sure how
many people career but yeah you know
that that was an episode that the yeah I
mean just you know dealt with the
psychology of you know look I mean the
age of the internet when you're walking
around with a little you know device in
your pocket that can access you know
naked pictures 24 hours a day and I mean
that's that's that's gonna affect
relationships that's that's gonna really
[ __ ] with people's heads and and it's
it's there there has to be some kind of
fallout for that and it's I thought that
maybe a little bit I probably sound like
a conservative without that well yeah I
mean there has to do our issues yeah it
doesn't mean ban it right it doesn't
mean don't let it happen but we should
face up to the changing realities energy
interact we just have to be aware of of
how of what your relationship is with
technology and then with Twitter is the
best example we're all on Twitter I
matter I [ __ ] hate it I don't know
about you your and I love it I've you
you do I do
yeah I mean I block people a lot yeah
and that's what but isn't that a tricky
thing because it's it's i used to do
that i still do it from time to time
just because i don't want to deal with
it but it's almost like a
people take it as a as a tacit
acknowledgement ya know they that yeah
they wear it as a badge of honor and I
said well you don't really want to get
mad you know III thought that for a long
time I muted people who I didn't like
and what I what convinced me was friends
who said if you mute somebody then the
rest of the people reading the comments
on your tweets still hear them all you
miss them whereas if you block them then
they just can't interact right it
Twitter's a weird thing because you're
broadcasting in to everybody do you
think there's any do you think there's
any positive at this point in - no I
think initially obviously Twitter was
this charming little little platform
that that was new and fun and we out you
know we would each write a joke every
day funny yeah do you do you think
there's any upside to Twitter at this
point in time I invited you this podcast
over Twitter okay well beyond this no I
made good friends over Twitter like I
have met people who I otherwise wouldn't
have met people become friends in real
life I learn about things I can follow
people I was just joking with this or
talking with a friend of mine last night
about this I tried really hard to follow
a bunch of conservatives yeah on Twitter
and I found that the only ones who I
could really like follow without
degrading my my state of mind were ones
who hated Donald Trump yeah those people
conservatives but the then there's a
whole swamp out there crazy people yeah
try hard to avoid yeah yeah it is tricky
is that you because I have you know I
have a lot of liberal friends obviously
I live in Hollywood I do have a fair
number of conservative friends and and
you know yeah there is a difference
between your conservative friend who
votes for Mitt Romney and your
conservative friend who votes for Donald
Trump like that that's it those are two
different types of people maybe maybe
there's more crossover than we'd like to
think and yeah I try to not let that
keep me up at night well I think you
know Twitter is you know Twitter and
Facebook and all these things we're just
in the beginning right there's a
technology that's changing everything I
do believe that we're gonna have
implants in our heads before too long
that will let us do this without the
intermediary the phone and there's lots
of science fiction and if we're there
there is a fear that I
I'm actually buddy who does not
subscribe to the fear that III think
this as much as I grass about Twitter
and and the these are at the early forms
of this technology I'd you know I do
think there's a lot of at the moment
destructive power that they seem to have
much more so than constructive but you
look at speed you talk about implants in
your head I mean you look at something
like evolution which has you know is is
real let's just establish that the
official minds but is staggering
you know brainless moronic thing that
makes its way through the through the
millennia having no and it stumbles on
us by accident yeah like at a certain
point you do kind of think to yourself
well we could do a better job and I and
there's a dystopian and where there's a
dystopian illness that goes along with
that yes and I don't and I think that
it's time to kind of maybe revisit that
idea because if you could I mean kinda
me if you could just tweak some things
in the human body that that that that
you know I kind of look at eating yeah
it's it's your body it's just evolution
still thinks that I'm out there with a
spear in my hand trying to hunt a boar
yeah it doesn't realize that no there's
like a McDonald's right there well I
think that that's the thing because we
focus a lot on AI and gap eaters but I
think that the making human beings yeah
where automated and changing them
editing them I've talked on the podcast
with synthetic biologists who are
building cells from scratch you know and
yeah that's it's that's why I say we're
just the beginning of what these changes
are gonna take really well how different
is that from using a drug to save your
life if you have you know if you have an
infection in some sense it's not right
but then so the thought experiment is
well what if I invent a drug it just
makes you happy all the time but you
never leave your chair is that an
improvement in your life or nothing it's
called jacked in to be some ya know
that's that and that's yeah that is it
that's a concern yeah brave new world
we're gonna ya be seeing some and and
I'm a huge believer that science fiction
helps us
just go a little bit toward thinking
these things through ahead of time yeah
that's well that's that's that's a big
job then
so Lourdes for those who have not seen
the show borders and Clyde and her
members of this race the maudlin and
there there are that we're told there
are only men only male Laughlin's but
they managed to give birth somehow which
makes me think that they're really only
female Macklin's but so I'm not quite
sure the definition we've I think we've
you know we've we've struggled out a
little bit the the the storytelling
value that that species gives you as
opposed to the logic of the biology of
what we've kind of landed on is all
right there definitions are a little
different than what ours are they're
very masculine presenting right they're
pretty macho because it you know it is
it is the end of the day you can always
fall back on it well they're aliens it's
different that's right but but yeah I
mean it's it's it's a it's an
interesting it was a dynamic that I
hadn't seen before these these two very
stoic you know kind of classically
science-fiction aliens who were who you
know we're a pair we're mates yeah and
and had this kind of domestic life going
on and it's it's I mean those two actors
are just gold I mean Chad Chad Coleman
who I think also does the expanse oh
yeah he was cutting on the wire now and
and Peter Macon obviously as bored us
are there I mean they're my favorite
couple on TV I can endorse that I guess
you could do a lot worse but then so I'm
going to mention in the introduction
that we're spoiling everything so that's
okay but they have a child it is female
this is a scandal and the cultural
expectation is that there will be a sex
change to turn it into a boring yeah and
I mean that is heavy stuff to be
tackling right there in season one yeah
well it's what what always fascinated me
was and again the specifics of that
episode and that conflict are are
arguably less
pertinent than the than the more general
conflict that's that's a play in there
and that's if you have another culture
that does things their own way that
doesn't doesn't stack up with your
morals and your code of ethics but it's
still their culture at what point do you
at what point do you respect their ways
and at what point does that get so
insane that you can't justify it in your
own mind or or or live with yourself and
it becomes time to be galaxy police and
clear I guess is the doctor and she
originally so her question was she is
also one of the treasures of the show I
was great I understand yeah she wanted
to know you know is was it she worked
through the ethical dilemma here you
know who's benefiting from this is it
medically necessary or is this just a
cultural thing and yeah I don't think
there's obvious answers to these
questions though those are my favorite
kinds of stories like I I and look as
much as much as I love as much as I
think there is a there is an absence in
television of noble people who just want
to do the right thing everyone's an
antihero and I do miss the simplicity of
you know Gary Cooper saying dammit I
just got married but I got to turn
around go fight this bad guy I I do
think that that's that's not a good
thing that that doesn't exist on on
television that I I when I was a kid I
had you know it was fiction but there
were people like you know Picard and it
was it was you know people who were
people who were just out to do that you
name the superheroes the Superfriends
forgot said they were so wholesome but
these were people who are just out to do
the right thing and I think at the end
of the day you to see people struggling
with what the right thing is but yet
coming from a noble place and coming
from a virtuous place but not being able
to find a clear answer those to me are
the most interesting kind of stories
that I can latch on
- I get a little weary of oh this guy's
a murderer and a drug addict and all
this and I'm supposed to sympathize with
them it's at a certain point it's just
I'm just watching terrible people do
terrible things it does wear you down a
little bit um you know it's it's is I
love The Handmaid's Tale but at a
certain point I start to get tired of
this girl getting kicked around it's I
remember I couldn't bring myself to
watch have you seen fleabag I haven't
seen fleabag it's really really good but
in the beginning it's just hard because
they're just so many bad things yeah
yeah yeah but it's but it is it is I
mean that's the most fun stuff to write
is those stories that don't have a clear
cut and that's what we're always looking
for on the orb all those stories that
don't have a clear cut what's right and
what's wrong and you know things that
things that um you know where you have
to weigh the rights of the individual
against the needs of the society it's
all interesting stuff and it's all stuff
that that science fiction is is arguably
more equipped than any genre to to
address and I I have a blast right in
those kinds of stories we had the fall
while watching some superhero movie that
like every superhero movie is a trolley
problem basically it's like the choice
between you know being nice to my friend
who I know or saving the universe yeah
and of course because it's a superhero
movie they usually figure out how to do
both but these are these are the real
dilemmas and and let me played out an
infinite number of different ways yeah
it's it's it's fun to leave that stuff I
mean look there are certain stories
where you it's it is clear like this is
this is right and this is wrong you may
disagree with me but I'm pretty
confident in my ethics I find that a lot
of what we do on the Orval is we we
struggle along with the characters it's
it's a tough thing to to you know I mean
that story is a good example this this
is this is their society but what
they're doing is really [ __ ] up and I
mean look I mean it's it's it's Saudi
Arabia is like a perfect example it's
it's their culture but you know look how
they treat women yeah I mean I'm not
when do you walk in there and say hey
you're gonna stop doing this and you're
gonna start doing things
whay you know people have differing
opinions I happen to believe that in in
that scenario there is an argument to be
made for being a little bit of a hero
and and helping out the the oppressed
but not everyone agrees with that some
people would say it's their culture it's
not your business yeah I'm on your side
in the sense I do you think sometimes
you're gonna try to intervene but but I
certainly historically recognized that
there's plenty of times when societies
have talked themselves into the idea
that they were the virtuous ones and in
fact they were just imposing their own
yap fuse right we've had crusades and
wrongs and the whole bit did you get
pushback for that episode by people who
have interests one way or the other in
gender reassignment or gender identity
we we didn't we
no certainly not for the company I mean
it was interesting about foxes is for
all of their conservatism on the news
side I've never once been censured in
any way when anything that I've done
III will I will say that for them and
you know when the episode aired that
there was there were there were mixed
reactions and and there was a lot of
passionate things written about the
story and you know again there are some
things that I read that educated me a
little bit and some things that I
thought were were a little bit maybe not
so correct in their analysis of the show
but it's you know overall the the
reaction that I found to that show and
it was gratifying was that hey at least
somebody's talking about this on you
know on a network yeah yeah and you'll
reach a different set of audiences than
the one yeah very passion on Twitter
yeah things right
well sexuality is are you definitely
going to be an area where science
fiction can talk about things that are a
little out there and you've done it
right you've had your human characters
have sex with with androids or with
robots with gelatinous blob
and you know something that was very
brave like the the scene where Claire
was having sex with the gelatinous blob
yes that's time we're gonna leave my
brain yeah that was yeah I mean again
god bless penny man she's like she's
game for whatever you throw at her and I
think that it makes the audience think
about like if I do find this icky why do
I find this icky is that is that
something you're intentionally going for
or yeah I mean it's it's it there's
there's no right way to answer that I
mean it's it's um you know do I find
this icky what I want to have sex with a
gelatinous blob probably not and that's
okay gelatinous Bob played by Norma
Donald yeah but yeah I mean it's it's it
leaves the door open for interpretation
in a lot of cases but in contrast when
she fell in love with Isaac the robot it
was not played for laughs in any way
right of secondary tender yeah well I
mean this you know the idea of the
artificial intelligence that's that's
trying to understand and trying to
communicate I mean that's always that's
a classic
it's a classic because it's it's convert
it's both warm and fuzzy and and funny
there's a lot of different colors that
that you can play with with a character
like that like those the the non-human
characters trying to grasp human culture
is always a great and it's always a rich
source of sci-fi writing but yeah I mean
I you know to me know I thought why not
I mean if at a certain point it's
reasonable to assume that an artificial
intelligence is gonna reach the point
where it achieves consciousness I would
think maybe it's happened already I
don't know but presumably at some point
that's that's not a crazy thing to to
think will happen and and so what you
know is that off limits like if I mean
that he's a person well we're we're
getting there I mean there's you know
the sex robots are definitely coming and
then the sex robots will be easier than
love interest robots yes they're gonna
happen
sure and then of course the question of
of Rights I mean you know it's like he
can't really have a sex robot that
sentient yeah yeah happy that would not
be moral um but it's it's uh it yeah
that that story was interesting because
it's alright and that I just wanted to
tell sort of a classic Hollywood love
story that and it was singing in the
rain you know these two very very
different people who you know what's
what's the what's the version of emotion
from somebody who can't feel right and
the best example of that that I can
think of was was Alan J learners
solution to Pygmalion when he was
writing the lyrics for my fair lady is
that song I've grown accustomed to her
face it's like that was that was his
solution to a love song that's not a
love song because Henry Higgins was not
a this was not an emotional character I
mean not not in that way
he was very you know a lot of
histrionics but he wasn't he wasn't he
was very cold and unfeeling and so it
made no sense for this guy to sing a
love song so what he latched on to is
that he had just become used to her
presence and that was I took a little
bit of that and applied it to Isaac in
trying to determine what it is about him
that would fit with his machine
mentality but would still would still
acknowledge her absence from his life we
can't really help but tell these stories
from a human centric interview it's very
hard to it's very hard to you know
because your audience is human yeah they
are mostly human and they're mostly
mostly human and therefore they've
always be this hint or this implication
that yeah the emotionless robot can
learn something from us yeah and maybe
there hasn't been enough of you know us
learning something from that I
completely agree I it's funny when I
used to watch the original Star Trek I
used to have that thought about Spock I
know that there was always this nagging
thing in my head that would scream this
guy kinda has it figured out seems like
what is every sub-zero's crazy but okay
this society is a lot more peaceful than
science and everything yeah but no I I
think absolutely that's true I think
that
look in a perfect world where the
Terminator doesn't come true you do
reach a point where you know in the
distant or not so distant future if
artificial intelligence is an element
that's a day-to-day part of our lives
that we do learn from each other so you
also talked about religion on the show
right you have the krill who are highly
religious basically religious fanatics
right do you but it didn't seem like it
was an element of the show but it wasn't
like an in-depth investigation of the
pros and cons yeah and in the third
season we're expanding we're we're
broadening that culture a little bit so
it's not just that one note it's it's
and I don't to give anything away but
it's it is um it's it's an element that
that it's whenever I write the krill I
have like there's always a different
idea of who they are in in in my head
you know are the krill are they are they
terrorists are they us are they there's
always as always you never really figure
out where it is they they land and and
you know they're always sort of a
metaphor for something well other than
robots
it seems implausible that an entire race
of creatures would be evil yes I agree
right so they're gonna have good aspects
and that's and that's where that's where
Thalia is I mean t'lay is one of my
favorite characters that I mean that
Micaela McManus was you know came in to
do a guest spot in this one episode and
she was so amazing that we just ended up
you know deciding this this is gonna be
a character that we're gonna see over
and over but it's it was the mähklinen
crunch she was the krill who the crow
woman who who Gordon ed the teacher yeah
yeah and in the second season we brought
her back and again those that that's
another one of my favorite go to sci-fi
stories is the enemy mine idea where
where I'm you know you you you look for
that commonality in me in the enemy and
it's always there it's always there
almost always I probably Hitler didn't
have it but for the most part it had a
mother yeah there is you know there's a
commonality there's there's I mean
that's the extreme version I you know I
do think that there's a you know when
you sit down with conservatives even
hardcore conservatives you do find that
you have a lot more in common than you
thought I mean nobody's nobody's going
into it wanting to be the bad guy
everyone wants to believe that they're
doing the right thing and and you know
that that I that idea of you know no
matter how is you say Oh matter how bad
the race is it's kind of irresistible
that eventually you meet one that is
that turns out to be you know somebody
that you can really surprise you in some
way well and going back to Twitter I
mean one of the things about our current
moment is we can demonize whole groups
of other people because we hear about
them all the time without interacting
with them right yeah exactly where else
and so we can hold this cartoon of them
in our brain yeah yeah I'm look I think
that happens I think that's happening
with with um we look Fox News made a
whole career of that I mean that the Fox
News made a whole brand of that rather
it it was this article recently like how
Fox News destroyed my family
you see them I didn't see that now it's
basically you know when I used to go
home and my parents or whatever would
have slightly reactionary opinions but
we could talk but now they think that
all my friends are the devil yeah yeah
it's it's it's um it's too
oversimplified I mean look Fox News
there's there's no getting around that
that network is is it's it's one of the
the instigators one of the big but some
would say the biggest instigator of that
kind of thinking I mean when when they
you know when I started the network it
was about storytelling it was creating
heroes and villains he's the good guys
and these are the bad guys people want
to see they want that simplistic
narrative they were talented at telling
the story oh yeah oh yeah and they say I
mean they still
and it's and it's I mean as destructive
as it is you can see the formula it's
it's about it's about us in them and you
know I never saw that from the other
side until the emergence of social media
yeah and I mean my god you know you make
a mild observation and conservatives
liberals I mean they'll all come after
you
so am I mistaken or is there I haven't
seen any social media on the Orval how
is that gotten rid of in the future it's
oh oh on the show our marketing people
on social media not social media on the
Orval yeah you know it's it's it's
something that was we felt was better
addressed as something that is elsewhere
the social media episode in season one
was a was I think a much more effective
use of of it it's hard there are certain
things that are cultural things are
really hard to depict in science fiction
without looking silly or looking dated
dated yeah I mean technology is easy you
know the uniforms are easy the ships are
easy but when you get into it people ask
me all the time how come they never
listen how come the music that they
listen to how can the pop culture as
always of our time and I I always have
to say have you ever heard future music
you can sci-fi that doesn't sound so
[ __ ] stupid it's there's no way you
can't predict it right you can if I
could predict that I'd be a billionaire
music so why not get a joke out of it
right oh yeah well it'll be there all
the time it's it's it's just it's just a
sensible you know those are things that
that are not we're not there to do that
job
as for the futurists and so I also like
you know beyond big themes like social
media religion or whatever you've had
some interesting episodes just about
personal anxiety impostor syndrome
roughly speaking John I guess it was we
learn at some point he's actual
the super-smart ingenious IQ but it's
been hiding it yeah in a way that you
know many people can probably relate to
mm-hmm and is that again is that where
does that come from is that personal
experience on the writers or is it is
there a mission to sort of tackle
questions like that is that that big
that was sort of a it was a little
simpler than I mean yeah look impostor
syndrome is is I think a lot of people
in Hollywood feel it that's this idea
that you're you're a fraud and you're
not really doing making anything great
and we have that knack edenia - yeah
yeah it's you know I I tend to look back
at things that I've written earth even
things that I'm in the process of
writing and and beat myself up and and
you know somehow convince myself that
I'm just I should get out of this and do
something completely different but that
was that was more of a result of the
need to give that character something
more to do I mean it's you have a
helmsman and a navigator side-by-side
and we'd made this whole deal about
Gordon being the best pilot in the fleet
and there's John sitting next to him it
compensated the two of them are great
together
but beyond that we wanted him to have
his own his own identity I there's you
know there was a little bit of a
sacrifice because they're so good
together that you no longer have them
sitting next to each other and you lose
a little bit of that but but what we
gained was a you know a an identity for
this character that really ended up a
giving us a story and B being the anchor
for this count rogues gallery and
engineering that you know it's a wild
world um yeah yeah in the engine room
yeah
and he's you know he's kind of the the
Steve Martin Roxann character who's got
to kind of corral the fire department
well that I think it's very interesting
for you know as an audience member
probably we attribute much too much
intentionality and planning to
everything that happens in the in the
story in the episodes but in fact
sometimes like there's a problem and you
have to fix it and that leads to new
story options right yeah it's it's
interesting reading there are times when
they've they've
they predict things well and they figure
it out and they're right that we have
thought this Adam you know the Isaac
Isaac turning on the crew was something
that was in our minds from day one so
that was that was Paul all part of the
plan but you know there are other things
that I will read and I'll react in such
a way I'll say to myself this this is
they where they think there were way
smarter than we are is they're way over
thought either a danger an opportunity
to get ideas by reading other people's
tweets yeah I think I think that's I
mean you you you never want to be in a
position where you're you're stealing
something from somebody but if but if
somebody says something about the show
like hey boy I'd love to see this or I'd
love to you know that that's all fair
game that's all for you that that's just
that's just responding to your fans and
and yeah I mean that's that's hearing
what the audience wants so I I do I do
pay attention to that stuff
you you definitely been it's a
science-fiction show but you're also a
science fan right for for its own sake I
think it the first time I saw you in
person was at the science and
entertainment exchange launch event yep
yeah my wife Jennifer was the director
of the Science Center oh yeah and that's
an organization that does a great amount
of good here yeah absolutely so how much
do you care about the science of your
science fictional universe it's it's
important well look that I have to
acknowledge that I mean the whole reason
the science and entertainment exchange
was created to to my knowledge is that
so many people get their science from
fiction they get their sign they get
their medical science from their law
firm y'all raise anatomy and they they
get their their law from you know CSI or
whatever Law & Order but so I think
there is a responsibility to to be right
I mean you know Andre is Andre Ramona's
for years a hundred Romanus been doing
this for years i if if there's something
that I'm hazy on you know I'll pick up
the phone and call you know Neil
deGrasse Tyson or or you know I mean in
many cases it I walk across the hall to
any dreams office
works in cosmos and not technically a
scientist but my god she sure talks like
and and you know you do try to do you I
mean my god I was gonna I was in a
session with my psychiatrist and and I i
stopped stopped in the middle to take
some notes about a story but let me ask
it this if an alien did this and he came
in here and he sat down on this couch
how would you react and you know so or
if I'm if I'm at a did I go for my
annual physical and I have a medical
question that relates to a story we're
telling I do try to get it from the
right sources you you you can you know
time will only allow so much of that but
you do try to be responsible if it's
something that's a story that's just too
damn good that requires us to stretch it
a little bit then we will but but we're
we're it's feasible we do try to be
scientifically responsible yes I'm a big
believer that the science serves the
story in a fictional you know fictional
environment you the science should be of
the form that it makes you not go oh
that wouldn't happen well it can't ever
feel like magic and there's one area
that you know Brendan Bragg and I have
talked about this is one area that we
both struggle with when we're writing
aliens is it the idea of a you know the
super-strength from a planet with high
gravity like you know that that I can I
can get up over that the one that the
one that I always struggle with is
telepaths ah that's the one that always
I can never wrap my brain around how
that doesn't feel like magic right how
this very basically you're basically
writing a psychic if you employ
technology into the mix then I start to
kind of see it but I don't even have a
teleporter machine a transporter machine
we don't that was that a conscious
decision was a conscious decision for
two reasons you know one one that it's
obviously so emblematic of Star Trek but
two if you if you study the science of
it you know this I do but you're killing
yourself basically you're not the same
person you're not the same person you're
you're committing suicide and being
reformed as a copy and as you it just it
just seems just seems like just
dystopian enough right that it didn't
need to be the shuttles do just fine
yeah you can trouble people around it's
actually again it's a bit more dramatic
it's eating you get cool shots the
orchestra gets to chime it I mean you
know obviously in the 60s they did that
because it was it saved money yeah but
now you can Photoshop can show the ships
leave it I mean those shots the shuttle
leaving the bay it's it's it's they're
nice and it's like it makes the world
seem real and this is a you know this is
a big deal when we launch one of these
things we're going down to a planet and
isn't that fun I do have to ask though
about time travel right we've introduced
a time travel last few episodes the out
of season two there as soon as you allow
yourself time travel there's a million
choices you need to get storytelling so
were there a lot of arguments
discussions in in the room about that
it's it's we recognize we're opening a
can of worms it's surprising how many
fans of sci-fi do have an aversion to
time travel they just really don't want
you going there it's a it's a dangerous
mixture
it's a dangerous mixture it's it's
always to me it's always fun like III
I'm a big fan of time-travel stories I'm
a big fan I loved that 11/22/63 that
Stephen King no never say FK
assassination I I was loved it you know
I mean you you you need only look as far
as Back to the Future to recognize the
narrative value the time-travel sir it's
it's you just have to be careful you
just have to be careful of I mean it's a
lot to think about and I think we think
we filled all the holes in that story
but I'm not sure well did you see
Avengers end game I haven't so there's a
line in there where all of I have to
find six hours I haven't learned yeah
that's true
where he says wait you because there's
time-travel in there yeah I was wait you
mean back in the future was just
[ __ ]
and I think that might be partly my
fault I was an adviser on endgame and
and I explained in detail why Back to
the Future was [ __ ] because yeah I'm
sure there's a lot I mean all the
paradox isn't Back to the Future are
undeniable well that says I get that
what would really I cannot stand in Back
to the Future you know it's a brilliant
movie like a cinema
wonderful but you know Michael J Fox
does something in the past and then in
real time we see photographs changing in
the present well versus it no frequency
ah Dennis Quaid movie recut he cuts off
the guy's hand in the past and then in
the future the guy watches his hand
disapper has the same thing yeah it's a
little silly thing yeah it's more than
also II but narrative Lee yeah as far as
I could tell really hard dear tells
stories though with I mean there was a
sort of Star Trek that did it very well
called yesterday's enterprise that was a
everything changed instantly and and and
that was you you were just in the new
timeline and that was it
science wise it's all actually [ __ ]
though and is it yeah yeah that's not
what would happen even if time travel
were possible that's not what would
happen the what would happen the most
sensible way to have time-travel is you
can travel the past but you cannot
change it but oh it's interesting so
that's I mean that's sort of what
Stephen King you yeah this book but so
certain elements of the universe
presumably seeming as if they are the
laws of physics would forbid it that's
right in some fashion like you can free
would fall before you so you see that's
really it yeah I think I think if
there's I've actually made small efforts
to make this happen I think there's a
wonderful TV show to be made about a
time-traveling detective yeah who can go
back and learn things about the past but
not change it and it sometimes you know
there's a murder or whatever you would
really really want to change it but
literally you know you can't and
therefore if you try but how would that
manifest itself well you don't know
ahead of time all you know is that you
will fail right so if you try to change
the past there's a danger that you know
you'll get killed or something like that
because you know it won't succeed
because it didn't happen that what does
it does that make the universe seem
almost like a conscious entity that's
out to it just means that there are laws
of physics yep that we're all obeying
right and and so what I try to pitch
this people are like well it's not
interesting if you can't change the past
I'm like well CSI is interesting like
detective shows are interesting they
can't change the past just to learn
things about it and if you were there
you learn it in much more dramatic way
so okay but but but even just by
visiting
past aren't you changed in the past if
we're really lucky the butterfly effect
you were always well as that that's the
point and they put it well and lost
whatever happened happened right yeah if
you went there
I mean Heinlein tells the story where a
character is his own mother and father
yeah but everything's completely
contestant that's an interesting story
that that I said we were playing with
something like that last season and
that's always an interesting story but
that's a hard one to crack oh yeah the
logic of that is always like you gotta
get your brain under pretzels but okay
but I don't know how entertaining it is
to watch yeah the standard thing to do
is have multiple timelines right that's
what we talked about it even maybe in
quantum mechanics that's actually
plausible who no one really knows but we
do it anyway but then here's the I have
a not a science issue with that but a
moral issue with it like when you have
as we've had in the end of season two a
separate timeline and things are bad
yeah I know okay so you send someone
back to fix it now you're back up to
good times yeah does that mean you just
killed billions of people and the other
timeline yeah probably yeah is that
world's greatest monster yeah I mean
it's it's it's that cold calculating the
needs of the many outweigh that needs
the few you made a better universe but
there's a whole universe that you got
rid of yeah yeah it's it's I mean that's
that's it that's a very good point I
think I think that's where you you you
you're faced with a choice and neither
one is I mean look that's those those
are the again what's the best kinds of
story it's a choice where neither one is
really ideal but you have to you have to
make a decision I know it's so much fun
time-travel I get it it's it's it's
irresistible fun yeah I mean you get to
put on the costumes alone but know that
yeah that is a that is an interesting
that's an interesting premise that it
that the universe will protect itself at
all cost yeah that's right now and in
the case where you can change the past
and fix the timeline probably this will
just be ignored going forward but won't
there be a forever temptation ever
whenever anything goes wrong to go to
the past and forget it I mean here's the
quite here's a question for the
scientists it I once read somewhere that
time travel to the future as possible
and time travel to the past is not yes
that's basically true right I mean the
way I joke about it is yesterday I
traveled 24 hours into the future and
Here I am
yeah right yeah but and move it one
second per second yeah you could
Einstein says you can go faster into the
future but he can never come back
right right right so Brian Greene wrote
a book called Icarus at the edge of time
here at a children's book and I was a
little surprised that this counter is a
children's book because you know Icarus
is the spaceship traveled close to a
black hole and Icarus the young child
was stranded near the black hole and
then rejoined the rest of civilization
later but because of time dilation
hundreds of years had passed and all
those family was dead and everything
like that's a pretty dark children's
yeah what what if if if a if a sci-fi
fan is is is looking to expand their
education as far as legitimate science
what are you've written a bunch of books
yeah what's what's what's like the first
Sean Carroll I have a book coming out in
September called something deeply hidden
about the many worlds of quantum
mechanics you know about the idea which
I actually think is true not science
fiction that when you observe a quantum
system the world branches into multiple
copies in each of which you've got a
different outcome and sadly you can't
talk to each other right the different
that's that's but I could easily imagine
science fiction scenarios that were just
very slight variations on that theme
where you could talk to each other or
influence right like it makes different
choices these are like parallel they're
parallel universes yeah like I said I
think this is actually real I don't
think that this is science fiction and
so they would have to be infinite
obviously right because at least a very
large number not necessarily in fit we
don't know as everything is the same
except this water bottle is a little
further to the right yeah that other
universe so in your body for example a
nuclear decay happens 5,000 times a
second so that means in every every one
of those decays why I'm so tired I know
every one of them makes a new universe
right so two to the five thousand
universes are created every second just
because of you decay so that's not
infinity that's a very large number yeah
yeah yeah versus yes yeah and there's an
app on your iPhone where you can split
the universe intentionally and then do
different things depending on what the
outcome was that's great so yes that's a
that's coming out in September and yeah
I think the influence that science has
on science fiction is a mixed bag right
like it can easily hmmm strong you him
yeah
hamstring you but it can also inspire
you yeah you know that's the big and
it's interesting that's where I think
Hollywood is a little off-track right
now because I think there's a heavy
heavy focus on on fear that the fear of
science and the fear of science gone
wrong and a lot less of the potential I
remember that kind of 90s it was
completely the opposite every sci-fi
television series was about hey we
figured this out I mean even the
terrible show like Seaquest yeah look at
that they figured that out you know is
about it was about the positivity of it
the adventure and the striving and now
it's just we all love the expanse but
it's a little depressing sometimes yeah
I mean it's it's it we you have to have
that in storytelling or or you just you
really start to it just becomes a drag
and that's kind of how it is right now
one of the greats of classic sci-fi
themes was always competence right like
yeah these people were super smart they
can solve puzzles and but you want to be
like yeah and I think that there's
plenty of satisfying stories to be
written about people doing good things
for reasons all right so I hear you have
other things going on will briefly
mention those right sure you have yes
yes yes yeah that's the yeah once in a
while that's out you don't have to do
this because my publicist told you there
might be people log in today yeah yeah
we have a handful of orchestral albums
that we recorded at Abbey Road that are
out on iTunes that are that are um Abbey
Road that's exciting yeah yeah yeah it's
it's like pressure I guess like
orchestral jazz that's
that's it's good place to look okay yeah
very very good and uh Congrats Orville
season three is gonna happen obviously
so are you what stage of the process are
you know we're in writing mode we've
written about we've broken about five so
we have our season pretty much mapped
out we've broken about five stories and
were deep in the writing it's another 13
episode kind of thing as of now it's
another 13 yeah yeah that's a standard
these days yeah well I was a child it
was 26 yeah I don't know how they did
that I mean I and granted part of it is
that television the television viewer
expects more now they want you know
cable and streaming have have made Rick
Berman used to say okay maybe people
relatively spoiled like they want it to
look like a movie every week and that's
fine but it just takes time it means you
can't do as many it things don't move
faster just because the technology you
still have to film actors doing things
you still know you need those pieces in
editing and so thirteen is is usually in
production I will say from my standpoint
thirteen episodes in is usually when I
start to come apart when I start to kind
of yeah you know stare myself in the
mirror and go I don't know I don't know
if I can go a second longer
inevitably for the end of both our first
two seasons that was when I just hit the
wall and I had I'm not in in this very
deeply but I have this feeling that for
features there's often this feeling like
we'll film a bunch of stuff and then
make the movie by editing them together
in the right way whereas for your for a
weekly TV series yeah you better get
better know what you're doing at a time
I mean look honestly that's that's a
that happens on both in both television
and movies if you know sometimes the
director is it understands editing
sometimes I mean to me the best
directors really have a sense of they
know enough to know that your editor is
as much a director as you are I mean
it's you if you can shoot with an idea
towards how you're gonna edit this thing
you're a lot better off because I mean
also editors hate it when when directors
will say let the editor figure it out
just give you all this stuff that they
like I mean please
the ones that I've worked with they like
to have some sort of a sense that
there's a there is a vision that there
is a shape to this and you're not just
asking him to clean up your mess you
know Jon Cassar who directed God the
lion's share of 24 is uh his hour come
main onset EP director for the Orville
and he's I mean he's just a fantastic
director when it comes to editing he
just he just has it has it in his head
and and you get into that edit Bay and
it's just all there so but as someone
who's been you've been on on both sides
is there more discipline on the TV side
just because of the scheduling well
necessarily there's there's there's some
really great directors in television and
some really bad directors in television
and it's the same for film it's it's
it's a and it's because it's I kind I
directed Ted I got on set and I I was I
had I had no idea
I've written a script I kind of knew
what I what I wanted this thing to look
like I had worked years in animation so
I had some sense of you know scene
composition and all that but I'm
relatively green and it occurred to me
that there must be a lot of people like
this who show up i sat in the director's
chair and really don't belong there yet
yeah I mean I had to ask my my director
of photography you know okay so what's a
fifty-fifty what's an over anyone over
is when you have the back of one
character you see a piece of them and
then here's the other character over
here did you go to films it's so I did
but but I mean I was I majored you know
it was a concentration in animation okay
um but even then I you know I just I
don't remember the Hollywood terms being
bandied about and and and it's and I
think there's look at me there's there's
a lot of talent and there's a lot of
fraudulence out there and I just thought
you hope that you know I've been lucky
enough to work with a lot of talented
directors but there are uh there there
are some where the editor has to clean
up the mess well we're all looking
forward to season three I'm very excited
what is it premiere you know premieres
it's looking like
fall of 2020 might be a little sooner
okay
but yeah it's I know it seems like a
long time it does yes it's not no I
understand it may be sooner but it's
it's uh that's that's the last thing
that I heard because it's because we
can't get it done in time with all the
work this show takes we can't get him
done in time for January okay and if
you're on a network
it's either January or write the fall
it's a crazy town we live in here yeah a
lot of fun things coming all right
thanks so much for being the pack so
much
[Music]
you
[Music]